quatre coachs de niveau international
pour 34 jeunes de 7 à 17 ans ici georges
klein williams ancien joueur de lincoln
university un camp de basket pour
progresser affiner les différentes
techniques de jeu et la formation et en
anglais en anglais parce que très
souvent ces jeunes joueurs ont un rêve
un rêve de performance qui s'appelle
michael jordan
depuis que je connais michael jordan de
fer avec 6 libye j'aimerais bien être
pensée ceinture et les bretelles ou
alors elle dit sa dette est sa cliente
on est quatre initiateurs de ce projet 4
avec exactement le même parcours ayant
commencé ici sur nous ils d'envoi doublé
martinique
[Musique]
et en tous cas c'est parisé dessus des
états unis certains sont hétéros une
carrière professionnelle
en europe espagne italie france donc
effectivement on ici pour redonner
pour guider aussi surtout mal et 15 ans
vit en france
son projet vivre en martinique être
formés en martinique et lui reste à
convaincre ses parents j'ai mon cousin
qui est passé par ici qui est maintenant
nationale de france et c'est comme mon
exemple on va dire il ne sais pas moi je
le sais et j'aimerais faire la même
chose que lui les mêmes parfois ouais
mais ici c'est plus intense et après ces
petits prêts des états unis pourra y
aller après on fait en guadeloupe et en
martinique pendant
les vacances de pâques on aura un camp
en floride pour qu'il touche vraiment
concrètement à
serait ce qu'ils ont pour certains et
pourquoi ça devient comptable
les entraînements sont en anglais pour
qu'il soit pour qu'ils s'habituent aux
termes techniques et pour gagner là bas
ils soient déjà
habituée effectivement donc qui meurent
qu'ils ne soient pas dépaysés quelque
part une formation intense 8h 17h qui
s'achève ce samedi des jeunes qui de
toute évidence se lève basket manche
basket et se couchent basket quand on
aime on ne compte pas